[موسيقى]
هجوم بمسيارتين قال الكريم انه حدث بعد
منتصف الليل والمكان المستهدف احد مباني
الكرملين في المنطقه المطله على الساحه
الحمراء والمغلقه بشكل كامل استعدادا لعرض
عسكري بمناسبه عيد النصر في التاسع مما
يعير الحالي ويظهر ان اجهزه الحمايه
الفيدراليه استطاعت رصد المسيرات واسقاطها
لكن اين كان الرئيس بوتين عند وقوع الهجوم
المتحرك الرسمي باسم الكرمنين قال انه كان
موجودا بمقر اقامته بضواحي موسكو فينوفى
اوغاريوفا ولم يصاب باي اذى ولم يتغير
جدول اعماله هيئه الطوارئ الروسيه اعلنت
ايضا سقوط طائره مسيره اخرى في مدينه
كولوم في ضواحي موسكو وتبعد نحو 110
كيلومترات تقريبا عن موسكو من غير الواضح
من اين اتت المسيرات وخاصه ان روسيا اتهمت
كييف صراحه بالمسؤوليه عن الهجوم لكن
بالنظر لطبيعه الانفجار وحجمه رجحت
تحليلات مختلفه ان تكون المسيرتان اطلقت
من داخل موسكو من مسافه قريبه يصعب على
الرادارات رصدها وتبقى فرضيه القدوم من
خارج الحدود وارده ولكن ضئيله وفق محللين
اذ في حال اعتبرنا ان هذه الطائرات انطلقت
من اقرب نقطه جغرافيه في اوكرانيا في شمال
سومي فيجب ان تكون قادره على التحليق
لمسافه تصل لنحو 600 كيلومتر دون كشفها
وهذا امر صعب
[موسيقى]